my name is Michael our genius I'm a PhD
student at the University of Birmingham
in England and I'm gonna be talking to
you about a Reese
which I've been working on called beta
fun so hmm this is working it's not
working oh no oh I know why it's not
working all right so a bunch of the talk
to you've probably seen today have gone
something like this here's this problem
we had boy was it a hard problem here's
a system we built and it solves this
problem really well this system is so
great in the future we're all going to
use this system this talk is a little
more exploratory than that data fun is
very early stages work and there is no
single problem that I can point to that
it solves better than any existing
system so instead of you know getting
into the details of how it solves some
specific problem I'm going to try and
discuss the ideas behind it and hope
that you'll find them as interesting as
I do and may be able to maybe be able to
take some of these ideas away and use
them so the driving idea here is what if
our programming languages were more like
our query languages and vice versa so a
lot of programs at its core a lot of
programs are manipulating data right
asking questions about it transforming
it you know shifting it from place to
place but our general-purpose
programming languages tend to focus more
on the computation side of things than
on the data side of things they often
make very simple things quite difficult
like if we want to put our data in
memory versus if we want to put it on
disk we have to do totally different
things we have to write totally
different pieces of code I want to worry
about all sorts of representation issues
and for these reasons data bases exist
right they give you a framework for
representing data that's fairly general
very nice they give you lots of useful
ways to operate over it they solve the
issue of like do you want on a disk or
do you want it in memory because they'll
keep it on disk and also loaded into
memory as needed it's very nice but you
wind up with a layer between yourself
and the data
because you're working in this
general-purpose programming language and
then you have to communicate through
this database and this causes what's
called an impedance mismatch right so
I'm sort of looking at what is the
smallest thing we could do to begin to
bridge this divide to begin to healers
divide can we find some happy medium
that merges what to me is
general-purpose programming to me
general-purpose programming is
functional programming that's sort of my
native language and database query
languages so this talk is kind of like
this first I'm going to explain what I
mean by a functional query language
because this idea isn't original to me
and it's a very nice idea and I'm gonna
explain what I mean by it and what data
funds take on it is then I'm going to
talk about data funds sort of
intellectual forebear data log and what
it's really good at and what features
data fun takes from it and then if I
have time I'm going to discuss my most
current work on data fun which is
incremental izing it that is to say
having it handle small changes to its
inputs or to the state of the database
if you prefer in a smooth fashion
without having to recompute everything
from scratch and this also turns out to
interact in an interesting way with
section two with the feature that we
inherit from data log so the normal way
of thinking about data well one way of
thinking about data the way that SQL
teaches us is your data is arranged in
tables right and a table has some number
of columns in each row has a value for
each of those columns right so here we
have a table that one might create if
you wanted to study the genealogies in
the work of Dera are talking and there
it is it tells you that era Thorne is
the parent of Aragorn Drogo is the
parent of Frodo and Galadriel parents
are a r1 and Finn are Peter and on the
right is a query that you might use in
this case it tells you who the parents
of Galadriel are right so it will return
Aaron and Finn Arvin right so
this kind of approach dates back to an
idea generated in the 70s like so many
computer science ideas called relational
algebra and that name is kind of a doozy
what do relations and algebra have to do
with tables and queries well
the relation part of it is what we'll
explain first a relation is a
mathematical name for a set of tuples
right and we can see a table as a set of
tuples every row becomes a tuple in the
set and the columns are just you know
which field which part of the tuple do
you want to get get at so you know our
our table can be looked at as a set so
this is a this is amounts to nothing
more than changing the way we look at
our data but once we've looked at our
data this way a certain question becomes
natural when we look at it from a
functional point of view tuples and sets
to a functional programmer are just data
types we have lots of data types lists
dictionaries or maps you know hash
tables trees anything you like so when
we certainly have tuples so why not sets
I want to just add sets to our language
right and some languages already have
you know set data types in them and then
another question presents itself which
is if tables are just sets what are
queries and the answer to this question
is the core idea behind functional query
languages which is you may have heard of
this you may have used list
comprehensions if you've programmed in
Python or in Haskell and there are very
nice syntax for manipulating lists for
iterating over them filtering them
applying functions to each element
combining lists well if we can have
lists second list comprehensions why not
set comprehensions right and it's
exactly the same idea except instead of
iterating over lists we're iterating
over sets and instead of producing a
list we're producing a set right so
suddenly order and duplicates don't
matter and my assertion is
anything that you do was a query in SQL
you can do with a second fraction all
right and set comprehensions provide a
very nice and natural way to express
queries so here's that query we saw
before finding the parents of Galadriel
and here's how you would write it and
this is valid data phone code this is
how you would write it in data fun right
so find me every parent where parent
comma child is in our parent-child table
parentage all right and the child is
Galadriel right so to give another
example to show that you can do some
more non-trivial things let's consider
trying to find siblings so here's the
SQL for finding siblings and it's a bit
noisy to me but it says let's find a
distinct two distinct children right who
have the same parent right we join our
parentage table on itself find two rows
in it would share a parent but have
distinct children great and you know
below is how you would write that as a
set comprehension all right so find me
you know parent comma a it you know I
find me an element parent comma a and
our parentage set find you know and
parent comma B where that parent is the
same as the previous parent which is
what that exclamation mark means it's
just a syntactic sugar for an equality
test and make sure that a isn't equal to
B because we don't want to say that
person is their own sibling so this is
almost all there is to say about the
idea of functional query languages
without getting into all sorts of
implementation details in their history
and so forth so here's our recipe
basically for a functional query
language take a functional language take
your favorite functional language
adsense as a data structure and add set
comprehensions as a way of manipulating
those data structures are we done can I
can I finish this talk
well there's a there's a burning
question that I haven't answered can we
make it go fast okay can this actually
do the things we want it to do in a
reasonable amount of time
and I believe it can but we have to
impose some limitations so I can't
convince you that every single
optimization in the database literature
carries over to this way of doing things
so I'm only going to give you one
example because there's a vast
literature on optimizing databases and
that example is sort of the simplest
smallest database optimization join
reordering or in a function language
loop reordering are these two set
comprehension 's equal right am I
allowed to see one of them saying now
that one run fast enough and turned into
the other not in general there are two
things that will keep me from doing it
side effects and non termination so side
effects the first you know these are
just these are just looping over two
different sets expert one and expert two
which are just standing for arbitrary
expressions right so if I put a
side-effect into my loop right like
printing a value depending on which
order I loop over things I will print
things in a different order that's
different behavior and that means I
can't replace one of these expressions
by the other I can't decide to optimize
one into the other all right so that's
pretty straightforward so it seemed to
make sense everybody hmm
okay the other one is a little more
tricky which is non termination so let's
suppose one of the expressions for a set
I'm looping over is the empty set right
which I'm representing here is you know
curly braces close curly braces right
and let's suppose the other expression
I'm looping over doesn't terminate it
into the loops alright so ever sent out
here with you know literally infinite
loop well if I run it the top way where
I'm looping over an empty set first well
looping over the empty set there's
nothing in it
so you're done immediately there's
nothing there are no results to your set
comprehension there's nothing for them
to do you get the empty set back on the
other hand if I loop over the expression
which fails to terminate first I'll sit
there waiting for it to terminate and it
won't and I will never give you back
your set that you wanted to get back so
non termination also prevents us from
making this optimization so what's my
solution and them no no side effects no
non termination pure and total
functional programming is what I want to
do so purity is fairly uncommon but
there's at least one language that some
people here will hopefully heard of
Haskell that is pure at least by default
totality that is to say banning on
termination all programs must terminate
is less popular but it's big you're
beginning to see some examples of trying
to make more or less general-purpose
languages that have totality as a
feature address for example can handle
both total and non total things so it's
an open question how how expressive a
total language can be but I think for
query language purposes it's probably
fine so we take a pure in total function
language we add sets insect
comprehensions and then we optimize and
of course this is the bit that's kind of
an open question how much can we
optimize can we get all of those things
that we had for databases and apply them
to sets and set comprehensions in appear
in total language and I think we can
most of them
so what have we gained from this
approach if it works well we're in a
functional language we can use functions
and higher-order functions we can factor
out repeated patterns we can do all
those things that were used to doing
right we have brought functional
programming and database programming a
little closer together taking baby steps
towards healing the impedance mismatch
also sets are now just ordinary values
you can do anything that you want to do
with them they're not these special
table things that have to be completed
with this one part of your language and
are they're different from numbers or
strings you can stick them in a closure
you can pass them to another function
you can nest them inside of another set
if you feel like it
and typically in databases databases
kind of have to make this global choice
about their semantics do they care about
duplicates or not all right SQL
sometimes can care about duplicates
relational algebra the idea invented
that 70s it was based on kind of said no
duplicates and you shouldn't care about
duplicates and there are holy wars about
this there is something called the third
manifesto that complains about how SQL
isn't really relational anyway my
solution is just like have them all
right use types to distinguish if you
don't care about duplicates if you want
to say there are no duplicates then you
have a set if you do care about
duplicates you have something called a
multi set or a bag and if you care about
duplicates and also about order you have
a list so you just use your type to say
which semantics you want okay but
nothing comes for free
what what is the cost of all this and
the cost is that we've just tried to
reinvent the world and now we have to
implement all that stuff and we have to
implement all the stuff that makes
functional languages hard to implement
and all the stuff that makes databases
hard to implement at the same time and
figure out how they all interact and
that's so this is one of the reasons why
I did it on this very early stage work
and we're going to focus probably not on
beating databases at their own game
so yeah there's a lot of stuff to
implement all right so that's basically
the first part of my talk now I'm gonna
talk and again none of basically none of
this apart from requiring totality it's
particularly new to data fun other
people have had the idea of functional
query languages before now I'm going to
talk about what really is new today to
fun and so I'm gonna talk about this by
introducing a particular problem and
solving it with another language called
data log so the problem is this we have
our data from before our genealogies our
token genealogies and we want to answer
this really important question is
arundel one of our gorn's ancestors
relational algebra the idea from the
seventies on which SQL is based cannot
answer this question it cannot do it
doesn't matter how clever you are it
literally cannot solve this question
because it essentially involves a sort
of unbounded search it's technically
bounded but you don't really know the
found in advance you're asking is there
until a parent or a grandparent or a
great grandparent or a great great
grandparent or a great girl great
grandparent any number of rates I don't
care how many greats I have to put in is
arendelle that many great grandparents
of and for any fixed number relation
algebra can do it but for an arbitrary
number it can't SQL technically can but
only because of an extension admittedly
it was standardized in the 1990s so it's
not particularly new but most
importantly it does not fit on a slide
so I'm not going to explain the SQL
extension that solve this problem
because instead I'm going to explain
data log because data log solve this
problem in two lines of code that are
extremely beautiful so date log this
this isn't data log yet did log comes
from the line of logic programming which
was this idea
that hold on why are we programming at
all why are we telling the computer what
to do why don't we just tell the
computer what it is we want why don't we
just specify the problem and have the
computer figure out how to solve it
it's a beautiful lovely idea
implementing it is hard data log is a
restriction of this idea to the cases
where you can implement it pretty well
right it's like let's scale down our
ambitions let's not try to solve every
problem by specifying it let's solve the
ones that we know how to solve just from
their specifications so here's a
specification for the question of when
somebody is somebody else's ancestor X
is Z's ancestor if X is YZ parent right
if you're a parent of someone you're
their ancestor and also if you're a
parent of one of their ancestors you are
one of their ancestors all right that's
the second line right this defines what
it is to be someone's ancestor but this
is English and English is hard for
computers to parse so let's try and make
this look a little more like logic it's
called logic programming because it's
based on formal logic so let's replace
our English possessives by something a
little easier to parse right we'll put a
predicate and then some arguments so in
this case the predicates were concerned
with our ancestor which tells us that
somebody is somebody's ancestor and
parent which tells us that somebody is
somebody's parent and just for kicks
let's make it look a little more
computery let's replace the if by a
colon - and the and by a comma there's
really you don't have to do that but
they did it's just what the syntax of a
log looks like and this this is valid a
log and it solves the problem we set out
to solve we took two steps from an
English specification of the problem and
we arrived at a runnable computer
program that solves the problem this is
what's so lovely about logic programming
okay
how do we make data fun solve this
problem the idea behind data log is that
it's it's deductive you give it a set of
rules like those if-then rules we just
provided and it chases them to their
logical conclusion it's not clear and
nobody's not immediately clear how to
capture this feature in a functional
language so let's try running a data log
program and see what it's doing and then
see if we can capture that so this is
how you run this is the naive conceptual
version of how you run a data log
program all right actual implementations
do smarter things okay so we're going to
repeatedly apply the procedure at the
top we're gonna pick a rule find some
facts that satisfy its premises which is
the things on the right-hand side of the
colon - which stands for if alright and
then if we can find something satisfy
its premises we're gonna add the
conclusion to the set of facts that we
know and we're going to start with just
two facts right they tell us that a
drill is the parent of arundel and they
are envel is the parent of LS
so before we start
what should the result look like at the
end what are all the ancestry
relationships here well it dual is an
ancestor of arendelle clearly and
arendelle is an ancestor of elros that's
just because their parents and there's a
grand Parenthood relationship here
Israel is the grandparent of L so we
should also have the Israel is an
ancestor of our rows so that's what we
should figure out so now let's try it
I'm gonna take a rule first rule why not
I need to pick a fat satisfying it's
premise first fact great so here X is
Adriel Z is arendelle so now we take the
conclusion and shove it into the facts
that we know all right so now we know
that a drill is the ancestor of Anne
Arundel now we're gonna do the same
thing faster alright so we know that
arendelle is the parent of LS and we
have a rule telling us that therefore
arendelle is Ellison ancestor great ok
now let's try the second rule for a
change
ok can we satisfy its premises well we
need that X is a parent of Y y literal
a parent of arendelle and now we need to
find someone who Aaron dill is an
ancestor of we looked at on our list and
the first ancestor fact doesn't match
because it's about a drill being the
parent of arendelle not a Rendell being
someone's parent but the second one does
and so now X is arendelle why is El Ross
and Zee sorry X is Adriel why is Aaron
del Z is el Ross and we add the
conclusion towards that effect and now
we are done why are we done anybody yeah
exactly right so he said if you reapply
the process you'll just find results
that already exist no matter which rule
we pick and no matter which facts we
pick satisfying its premises we're going
to derive effect that we already know
and this is not immediately obvious from
looking at this but a computer can check
it it's not too hard and so we're done
because nothing is changing anymore
right so what we just did was we
repeatedly applied a set of rules until
nothing was changing anymore how could
we capture this in a functional way
I heard the word fix point which is
great but you're jumping a little bit
ahead instead of a set of rules let's
use a function which is functional
programming after all a function is kind
of like a set of rules or more like a
single rule so we'll see whether this
works it's just a hypothesis and what do
we mean my by nothing is changing well
we're repeatedly applying a function so
we repeatedly applying it until the
output that we get at some point is
equal to the input that we just applied
it to and the name for this is a fixed
point right because it's a point of
value X such that f of x equals x it's
fixed if we keep applying the function
we're not gonna get anywhere new and
this is what deta fun
does and this is the data fun syntax for
finding one of these things you say fix
x equals and then you write an
expression in terms of X and it will
repeatedly it will treat that expression
as a function of X and repeatedly apply
it starting from the empty set start out
knowing nothing why not it's a good as
place to start as any until you reach a
fixed point so here is the translation
in today the fun of our running example
all right so it's not immediately
obvious what's going on here but let's
split this in two parts the first part
so this is a union of two things right
that's what you means Union two sets the
first part corresponds more or less to
the first rule it says if some tuple or
pair is in the parent set then it's also
in the ancestor set all right if X is a
parent of Y then they're an ancestor
play the second part is the interesting
one right it's one where we need to bust
out the set comprehensions right and
it's looking for you know a pair XY and
parent and a pair Y Z and ancestor where
those two y's are equal right so just
show of hands how many people think it's
clear that the thing on the bottom
calculates the same as the thing on the
top okay some hands
but not enough so we're gonna run it and
show that it calculates the same thing
alright so here's the function that we
want to apply I've just taken ancestor
and replaced it with big X right here's
the definition of parent that we're
using right that's those are the
parentage relations we're starting with
and we're gonna start with the empty set
that's what circle with a slash through
it means empty set so alright we
substitute empty set into our function
as big X we get this expression okay
what is this expression they evaluate to
well I can use a trick because the right
hand side comprehension is looping over
an empty set it's going for every Y Z
and empty set and there ain't nothing in
the empty set so that whole thing
produces nothing it's empty so this just
turns into parent this is just parent
okay alright first iteration done
let's apply our function again so now
let's look at this for a while what is
it's doing it's taking parent Union this
thing that looks for pairs in parent
that have a common middle thing where
one of them's child is the same as the
other one's parent so this is in other
words calculating grandparents this is
parent Union grandparent and if we
actually calculate that out this is the
set you get and this is exactly the set
of things that we knew if we go back to
our data log example at the end these
were the ancestors and this happens to
be a fix point of this function if you
run it again nothing will change right
so I tell if I've convinced you that
oops I hope I've convinced you that
fixed points are as expressive as data
logs ability to define predicates
recursively by rules which reference
themselves such as the rule for ancestor
but can it go fast alright and this is
the part where I admit that I don't know
but I have reason for hope and that
reason for hope is that we've just as of
about three weeks ago figured out how to
apply one of the optimizations that's
standard in the data log literature to
data fun right and we found out that
it's equivalent to another thing as well
so the third part I'm going to talk
about incremental izing data fund how am
i doing on time how many minutes do we
have okay yeah twelve minutes sure so
here are three problems that it first
seems separate view maintenance you have
a database this database is changing and
changing all the time people are sending
up states to it but you also have a
cached query something that's called a
view in a database right you tell your
database here is a query please maintain
the results of this query for me so that
I can very quickly ask for its results
again it's not quite a cache but it's
close enough
right and we want to keep this view
up-to-date even if the database is
changing behind us but we don't want to
have to re execute the query from
scratch every time because that will be
slow so how do we do this I'm not going
to tell you I don't have time but here's
another problem so data log can be
thought of as a deductive system
repeatedly apply rules or people would
deduce things but in that example that I
showed you a running data log I sort of
magically picked the rules that I knew
result in something interest
it's not clear how to do that in general
how do you avoid picking a rule that's
gonna generate a result you already know
about and finally incremental
computation which is this idea from
functional programming languages and
from programming languages research in
general you have a function defined in
some language and its inputs change by a
little bit you want to rerun the
function to compute the updated output
but you don't want to rerun it from
scratch because that would be slow and I
assert that all of these three things
well the previous two things are just
special cases of the third thing right
so with view maintenance that's a not
too hard to accept right a view a query
is just a function of the state of the
database and when the inputs to that
function change ie the database updates
you want to figure out how the output ie
the cached query changes without
recomputing it from scratch it's a
little less obvious how data logs
recursive queries how avoid how not how
trying to avoid applying rules that
generate boring facts things you already
knew is related to this so there's a
paper that describes a solution to
problem 3 that is the paper that we've
based our work on data fun in that
solves problem 3 and problem - except
for data fun rather than data log it has
a rather intimidatingly long title a
theory of changes for higher order
languages incrementing lambda calculi by
static differentiation and the way it
works is like this every type gets an
Associated type representing changes to
that type right so how that thing might
be updated so for example natural
numbers right number 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 there
type of changes is going to be the
integers because they might increase or
decrease right if I turned 3 into 2 the
change that does that is minus 1 right
if I have a type of pairs in my language
then a change to a type of pair is going
to be a pair of changes the change the
first part of a pair and the change the
second part of the pair and you go
through every type in your language and
figure out what the type of change is
for a given type should be every type
also gets a little operator that adds a
value and a change and gives you the
updated value it's that simple
right so for natural numbers with
integers change things you're literally
just adding them right for pairs you
just pair wise updating each part of the
pair and a here's the interesting part a
function gets a derivative so this is
the collected notion of derivative from
calculus but it's somewhat similar
because it tells you how your function
changes if F takes things of type a to
things of type B the derivative takes a
value of type a a change to it of type
Delta and produces the change in the
output all right so to sort of explain
how this is different from regular
calculus let's say our function is f of
x equals x squared squares the value the
derivative then is going to take the
value X and a change to it DX and this
is the result it's going to give right
why why is that the correct derivative
right because that isn't what you can
call the calculus derivative the
calculus derivative of x squared is 2x
right so why all this extra extra junk
well because we care about computing
exact changes not just the local
approximation right and if we add the
function and the function that computes
the change right we get this expression
x squared plus 2x DX plus DX squared and
if we manipulate that a bit without
Jarell we get x plus DX squared which is
just the original function applied at
the updated input right so the
derivative lets you compute what the new
value of your function will be so right
we have as of three weeks ago figured
out how to extend this technique to
apply to all of data fun so all
expressions get a derivative that tells
you how they change that their inputs
change
the only implementation of this
unfortunately is in my notebooks and end
in a github repo but not code yet we're
working on it so how does this help us
find fixed points pastor alright because
I promised you this would help us find
fixed points faster help us solve data
log queries faster which turned out to
be just fixed points so the normal way
to find a fixed one looks like this you
start with the empty set you apply your
function you apply your first again you
apply your French in again you keep
doing it until you at a fixed point
sorry straightforward but the the
neighbors in iteration pattern you know
are going to overlap a lot they're going
to share a lot of information and
generally computing the next step from
the previous step ends up recomputing a
lot of things and we'd like to avoid
that so what if we could only compute
what was changing between iterations and
now maybe we begin to see how
derivatives could help us because they
help us compute what changes and only
what changes not the whole thing so
these are the equations that we use to
figure out the fix point of a derivative
faster using the fixed point of a
function faster using the derivative of
that function so the idea is that we're
going to have a sequence you know x0 x1
x2 x3 that is going to be the same as
the sequence of iterations of the
function that we had earlier empty set s
is empty set F of F of empty set and so
forth but we're auxin I have a sequence
of derivatives that is going to help us
find it faster so the initial value of x
is is empty set that's where we start
the initial change is f of empty set
because that's the next value and we're
representing changes to sets as just the
set of things we add to them
right so the kick off the the thing we
start with the change that we start with
is going from empty set to F of empty
set and then to calculate the next
actual value the next X we take the
union of the previous X and the change
to it right that's how we apply a change
we just Union and then the next the part
where we use the actual derivative
is the next change value the next value
of DX is going to be the derivative
applied to the previous actual value and
the previous change right and it's very
simple and it works whether it makes
things go really fast we're not sure yet
because we haven't implemented it but we
hope so
takeaways from this talk set
comprehensions are a really powerful
query language they let you do
everything you want might want to do an
SQL fixed points let you do recursive
queries like you can do in data log
which can help for solving certain sorts
of problems and incremental computation
which is that's very general idea it's
useful in its own right also helps you
find fixed points faster and we think
generalizes one of the standard
optimizations in the data log literature
called semi naive evaluation which I
didn't talk about because well I think
it's just that faster fixed point data
Thun has all three of these things or
soon will so that's that's my talk
and I think I have some time for
questions if people want to ask
questions yeah
I don't think so so laziness
representing right so the question is in
the motivating example for why use a
total language why not just use a lazy
language would that solve the problems
that we're trying to solve and the
answer is I don't think so because even
in lazy languages you can write
expressions that don't terminate at all
you just ask for their value and they
just like nope right and ask well you
can do this with let x equals x right
it's really easy all right anything you
do with X it's just gonna hang right so
the optimization that we'd like to do a
loop reordering is still invalid even if
your language is lazy and laziness adds
all sorts of difficult problems like how
do you represent sets lazily and also
efficiently and at least as far as I
know it doesn't interact nicely with
this iterative fixed point approach
because this iterative building-up fix
points from empty set is kind of feels
very eager to me I could be wrong about
that one so I'd be interested I don't
know so Prolog so the question was
expert systems in the past which were
built on Prolog presumably had similar
problems and maybe had some way of
solving them and my answer is I don't
really know whether they did I don't
know all that much about Prolog work
I know Prolog itself is can you can
express is the Turing complete so you
can't have non terminating things in
Prolog but just like you can have non
terminating things in Haskell but you
still do useful things in Haskell you
can still do useful things in Prolog so
for us non termination is important
primarily because we want to optimize
things I don't know whether Prolog makes
optimizations on the assumption of non
termination or not
right it takes an a and a change to a
and produces the change to be the change
in the output yeah okay and yeah
yeah so the question was some of the
problems that people have run into in
trying to embed relational algebra like
stuff into functional languages is
things like group by and other forms of
aggregation which aren't exactly folds
was that yeah okay yeah so aggregation
is an important thing and we hope to add
it to data fun but we haven't done it
yet we have some ideas we think that
just as sets and set comprehensions are
related to semi lattices bags and bag
comprehensions and aggregations that
we're cover bags are related to
commutative mono AIDS so an example of
an aggregation that is a commutative
mono would be adding things that added
addition is commutative it's associative
and it has an identity element zero that
is what I mean by a commutative monoid
right so you have something that does
nothing it have to be zero it's
commutative and it's associative right
and reductions over lists similarly you
just need associativity and identity so
we think that there is a relation
between various ideas in abstract
algebra and how aggregations work but we
haven't fully chased those up there have
been some people who have chased this
idea there's some paper by voodoo and
talk in that whose title I forget it's
something like multi linear programming
for Big Data so yeah we have some ideas
but do not have a solution for that
problem yeah
sure so the question was sort of is
there relationship between this system
and bloom which was the system that God
talked about it strange loop a few years
ago so not not directly I was kind of
indirectly inspired by bloom to start
thinking about these kinds of problems
bloom is a tool for tackling distributed
systems problems whereas this is just a
query language and we have no idea how
to distribute things on it or how to
tackle the same kinds of problems but
there are definitely similar ideas going
around and certainly both of both bloom
and this and data fun Oh a lot to data
log
right so data log I think is getting a
bit of renewed attention at the moment
which is well-deserved it's a really
cool language and a really cool idea
so no direct relation but definitely
some shared inspiration I think maybe if
there are more talks we should take them
offline so thank you
[Applause]